[Music]
will I be brave like you one day
remember when I told you to shoot the
deer you said no
how's that coming along we finished by
the time she's 16.
[Music]
Mr Logan
situation with your son is dire
ctor he appears before this court again
he'll be taken from your care
colorful how'd you know where I lived
right under surveillance
I need your help son
whatever it is it's off of me you've
forgotten about Tony McManus no I did
that
because you're my brother
you going hunting
sounds anyway yes sir Ned we're good
it's not yet
you're a soldier
you did what you had to do
what
[Music]
no well I'm just wondering
if you know anyone else out there in the
game it's got the same skill set as you
you wish she was still here and not me
you want to know I run away come on
because you don't want me Dad
[Music]
we're all just met
we're not Invincible just trying to walk
a line between courage and fear
[Music]
it stops yeah